[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo
[Música]
el llamado sueño americano es para
millones de personas un salvavidas ante
la pobreza la violencia la persecución y
los desastres naturales sin embargo
durante los últimos cuatro años fue un
sueño frustrado por las políticas
migratorias restrictivas del anterior
gobierno en eeuu con la llegada de joe
biden a la presidencia la esperanza
regresa para los inmigrantes y
solicitantes de asilo que esperan una
oportunidad en un país nuevo días antes
de la posesión de la nueva
administración en la unión americana una
caravana de hondureños partió hacia el
norte fueron al menos 9.000 personas en
tránsito contenidas por las fuerzas de
seguridad en guatemala la caravana fue
disuelta y miles fueron deportados al
tiempo que méxico acercaba sus fronteras
para impedir el paso se trata de una
movilización que partió expectante ante
el cambio de gobierno en eeuu
y es que justamente una vez joe biden
llegó a la presidencia firmó seis
órdenes ejecutivas que buscan revertir
algunas de las directrices migratorias
del gobierno trump detener la
construcción del muro en la frontera sur
fue una de ellas méxico juega un papel
crucial para la unión americana en el
tema migratorio
[Aplausos]
nuevos vientos soplan entre méxico y
eeuu
el presidente joe biden lleva muy pocos
días en la casa blanca y ya ha avanzado
en la supresión de varias políticas que
tensaron las relaciones con su vecino
del sur durante la era trump en este
periodo optó por proteger el estatus de
jóvenes indocumentados que llegaron
ilegalmente al territorio estadounidense
cuando eran niños suspender la orden que
obligaba a los solicitantes de asilo a
permanecer en mexico y detener la
construcción del muro en la frontera
entre ambos países con el que el ex
mandatario dijo que frenaría el crimen
que cruza desde méxico lópez obrador
celebró la decisión de frenar el
levantamiento de la barrera fronteriza
el que diga el presidente
que ya
no sé construir el muro quiere decir que
en estos cuatro años cero la migración
siendo un tema espinoso entre los países
obligó a méxico a adoptar estrictas
medidas para detener el gran flujo de
personas que entraban a su territorio
buscando llegar a eeuu
pues yo estoy contento con el nuevo
presidente pero que quiero que se cumpla
lo que él digo en cómo entonces que
quiero yo que cumpla lo que prometió que
dice que no va a haber un deportación y
que el mpp está suspendido porque yo no
quiero discutir mi caso asilo político
en méxico y quiero discutir en los eeuu
ganármelo y aunque el gobierno va a ir
en se ha comprometido a revisar el tema
migratorio advierte que la frontera sur
está cerrada para todos aquellos que
quieran ingresar de manera irregular a
eeuu
tras tomar posesión baiden envió al
congreso una ambiciosa reforma
migratoria que abre el camino para la
legalización de 11 millones de
indocumentados los primeros en
beneficiarse de esta reforma serían los
llamados gamers más de 700 mil jóvenes
que llegaron de manera irregular al país
cuando eran niños y que aún no tienen
papeles nuestro corresponsal
anthony belchí habló con una de ellas
ya me toca empezar a aplicar escuelas
porque ahorita es el tiempo que están
agarrando a jen jeans y lleva casi toda
la vida en eeuu llegó a los 2 años al
sur de la florida procedente de honduras
pero lo hizo ilegalmente junto a su
madre y ahora no tiene papeles vive con
el miedo de que en cualquier momento
pueda ser deportada a un país que ni
siquiera conoce y todo este tiempo he
estado en un limbo porque no sé cómo voy
a seguir una carrera normal como
persiguiera una diploma de la
universidad sin el papel que me falta
aunque me siento más americana que
hondureña
es una más de los 700.000 jóvenes
soñadores los dreamers que han podido
acogerse al programa daca barack obama
lo impulsó en 2012 por orden ejecutiva
para que pudieran tener un estatus
temporal
trump ha luchado sin suerte para
cerrarle la puerta ahora y en si está
esperanzada con que la nueva
administración y ambas cámaras de
mayoría demócrata aprueben una reforma
migratoria definitiva ahora que el
gobierno senado y el congreso son del
mismo color me siento muy esperanzada
que va a haber cambio de verdad y
efectivo para nuestras comunidades vamos
trabajando
en la lucha la de los dreamers que ha
sido apoyada por cientos de
organizaciones en todo el país o lo que
necesitamos de forma urgente y de forma
crítica ya es una permanencia para
nuestros casi 12 millones de personas
indocumentadas muchos de ellos
trabajando en sectores esenciales como
lo que es agrícola en el sector de salud
la mayoría de los republicanos ya ha
expresado su rechazo a la reforma
consideran que un cambio en la
legislación vigente provocaría un
aumento de los flujos migrantes al país
tratarán de toda manera de entrar a los
estados unidos en espera de estatal a
amnistía aquí no va a haber como ni
siquiera ayudar a los que están en la
fila esperando su turno
pero la administración baiden ya ha
avisado una reforma no dará vía libre a
la entrada ilegal su prioridad es
encontrar una solución para todos los
indocumentados que actualmente no gozan
de una protección legal en eeuu
la propuesta del gobierno de joe biden
sobre migración contempla además como
prioridad mantener a las familias unidas
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
siga con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]